hi i'm aaron from phenotype and we are
here the tata headquarters in Beijing to
find out who can do the best trip shots
and we have some special guests with us
what's your no one else should you one
yes oh you want you wash your phone here
make sure they are going to Hualian jump
at the hodo joke
oh yeah hi sure open the door hit the
ball and close the door
nubile young can you do this
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
how about hitting two balls consecutive
[Music]
funky EM wave can move down the cups
easy
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
this is our conveyor belt I'm gonna
choose two moving dots
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
for this next trick shot I'll be
standing up there seven meters high up
and I hit the ball into the cone
[Music]
next its ball floating time
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
bye-bye
big thanks to Tata for having us here if
you think you can do a better trickshot
record it and send it in
[ __ ] [ __ ] that up see you next year
[Music]